welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about whether or
not your soul looks like you or a hard
candy that you got out of one of those
25 cent machines at the front of the
grocery store when you were little i
love them even though my mother would
never give me the quarter why mother we
wouldn't go poor my name is mt and i'm
here today with my fellow big head gang
buddy brother tommy what's going on yes
big head gang
my dad actually was a vending machine
repairman when i was a little kid so he
used to teach us how to steal from those
machines he's like we're already poor so
it's fine
25 cents will make us more poor
tommy yes oh yes today's question is
based on the recently released shangshi
and the legends of the 10 rings heard of
it it's only the biggest thing on all of
the internet for both lovers and haters
of it is this the biggest flop ever no
it's not it's actually incredibly
successful you clowns all right anyway
if you haven't seen it stop this video
go to the movies get one of those movie
theaters with a reclining seat get some
popcorn get some caramel m m's mix the
popcorn and the caramel m m's get a diet
barks vanilla root beer from the
coca-cola freestyle machine
go see the movie then come back hit play
on this video because we're about to
talk about how in shangshi shanxi shanxi
i you know what i shouldn't mock it if i
don't know how to say it uh but i
believe
shanxi sounds like how the people who
are in the movie say it
we saw how the soul sucker minions of
the mega soul sucker were stealing the
souls of the villagers of tao lo to feed
their master which i mean who hasn't
done that for their boss steal a few
souls and feed them i used to work at a
pizzeria where we had to come in with
two three souls a shift if we wanted to
work anyway
it was yet another example of souls in
the mcu a very common theme there's even
a whole stone based on it so that got us
thinking about a big question
after shanxi how has our understanding
of souls in the mcu expanded we have
dived into the topic of souls and the
afterlife before on big question and in
a previous episode we discussed whether
or not vision is alive and has a soul
and we've also looked at how the
concepts of souls has been addressed in
mcu films like doctor strange and black
panther through the concepts of the
astral dimension and the ancestral plane
and check out these episodes if you
haven't already to see what we've
already discussed because it's some good
[ __ ] let me tell you it's not i'm not
just saying that because i work here
it's a good [ __ ]
there's a cut that philip with a gun
just off camera plug the video the most
infamous way we've seen souls expressed
in the mcu began when the ancient one
first pushed steven strange's soul
outside of his body when he first came
to comtaj looking for all that magical
skill so the way the ancient one
described it she pushed the astral form
out of his physical form but is the
astral form actually just your soul the
astral dimension is a place where the
soul can exist separate from the
physical body so it would make sense
that the astral form is a good
representation
of the soul and this would also explain
why we see the ancient one do the same
trick on the hulk in endgame because we
see the astral form represented just as
bruce banner rather than the hulk
because that's the soul of the hulk as
bruce banner yes and the trailer for
spider-man no way home shows doctor
strange doing the same soul push trick
to spider-man it's one of the biggest
parts of the trailer this is the coolest
part i love a good soul push doctor me
too i you know i used to soul push my
little brother all the time and then one
day i did it too hard
you're still pushing your little brother
at the playground it's like hey back off
man
just like oh [ __ ]
now we have a new way of looking at
souls thanks to shanghi and the legend
of the ten rings and it was yet another
example of how the concept of humans
having souls has been canonized within
the mcu even the bad guys have souls
[Laughter]
even them well i i don't know if um i
don't think jeremy renner has a soul i
think we all once he launched that phone
app i think we all decided he had no
song oh my god i'm still on that by the
way i'm getting a ton of dates from the
jammie runner app i'm hooking oh damn
it yeah i hear only the hottest chicks
are on the jeremy
r-e-n-n-r
runner
the mega soul sucker aka the dweller in
darkness was the creature that when we
released from the gate in tallow and
this beast gains its powers from the
souls of living beings and these souls
were fed to the beast by the soul eaters
not the anime the soul eaters the little
monsters the little flying tentacle
monsters that couldn't be harmed with
traditional weapons and when they would
steal a soul from someone we would
physically see the soul manifested as a
translucent
rainbow-colored ore being dragged away
from the body and this is the first time
in the mcu that we've seen a soul
represented other than just you know a
semi-transparent version of the person
or a black panther hanging out in a tree
on the ancestral plane though
i kind of do like that second one when
the ancient one and doctor strange enter
the astral dimension the form their soul
takes resembles their physical bodies
and the same thing happens when t'challa
enters the ancestral plane which has
been theorized to also be a type of
astral dimension and in chongqi we now
see that souls are represented by orbs
and perhaps this is a result of how the
soul eaters pull the souls from the body
and maybe their tentacles allow them to
form the soul into a sphere hysterical
making it easier to drop right into the
dweller of darkness's mouth like some
type of i don't know candy ball that you
get from outside the grocery store like
a pez like a soul pass yes yes sopez
exactly
another new feature with souls that we
saw in chongqi was the instant death
brought about when a soul was removed
from the body as we all assumed in real
life because that doesn't seem like your
body would function well without a soul
though you know politicians
they seem to be doing all right yeah ted
cruz is thriving we've seen plenty of
instances of the soul existing outside
of the physical body in the mcu without
the physical body being technically dead
and in doctor strange when christine
palmer was working on stephen's body in
the hospital and his soul enters the
astral dimension separate from his body
his body still has a heartbeat and is
technically alive and the same can be
said in end game when the ancient one
pushes bruce outside of smart hulk's
body when we see the soulless hulk just
laying there in the garden hat he is
still breathing he's just taking a
little nap which is pretty nice imagine
if that was like a viable way to take a
nap it's just like hey honey i'm feeling
kind of tired it's like hey baby don't
even worry about it
and just not go to sleep
that'd be amazing i'd like that
he's just resting in pieces that man is
dead
however things are a little bit
different when the soul is removed from
the body in chiang chi because when we
see a soul eater rip out the glowing orb
soul suddenly the person is instantly
dead and we see this happen with death
dealer guangbo and wen wu as soon as the
soul is gone boom they're gone the dead
instant is this a result of the process
of how their soul is removed could it be
that the soul eaters are taking more
than just the soul it's possible that
they're stealing the entire life force
of the person along with the soul and
this might be represented by the glowing
mist around the victim's body but
perhaps it has something to do with the
fact that the soul is taken away that
kills the person in previous instances
of the soul leaving a body that we've
seen in the mcu the process has been
done in an intentionally magical way
like the masters of the mystic arts use
eldritch's magic to separate souls from
the bodies whether they're interesting
the astral dimension on their own or
pushing someone's soul out of their body
they're not doing it to kill the person
rather they're trying to teach some sort
of lesson or provide some new
perspective and the same is true in
wakanda when they're performing the
ritual to enter the ancestral plane the
person in the ritual is not trying to
die but rather speak with their dead
ancestors but the important change that
chongqi makes to our understanding of
souls in the mcu is how it's possible to
instantly kill somebody by removing
their soul it's also possible that there
is more than just a soul that makes up
our internal consciousness and there
might also be some innate life force
tied to that as well as we're you know
probably going to get into the topic of
life forces in the eternal movie coming
up in november so this could also be our
primer for you know that as well another
thing to consider is how having your
soul devoured by the dweller in darkness
might affect any transition to some sort
of afterlife if we believe that in the
mcu it's possible for your soul to
transition to some form of afterlife
like the ancestral plane if you wind up
in the dweller of darkness's belly does
that mean that you just get no afterlife
is that what that is that what that
means i hope you get to live in the
dweller of the darkness's stomach
seriously i feel like the only people
that shouldn't get to go to heaven are
the people that keep killing vision over
and over again yes you don't get to see
you keep hurting me
if this is true then that reality is a
very dark fate for whoever got their
soul devoured in shanghai and you're
like you know when whoo however it's
possible that the dweller in darkness
was destroyed by shung chi then all of
those souls would be released and free
to move on to their respective afterlife
though i would assume that when wu
should probably go to whatever form of
hell that there is in the afterlife
because you know he uh he lived a couple
centuries of uh doing some terrible [ __ ]
he killed a lot of people uh but maybe
he can have a fun slow motion fight in
the woods with hella
and then and then 20 years of being a
nice guy
he was like i got married popped out two
kids i was nice for 12 years of my life
of my thousands of year life kids will
do that to you man kids will make you
stop murdering people for a little kids
they'll mail you out for sure that's
what they say i can't keep murdering
with this cute baby here i can't i'm
gonna put the rings in my hope chest for
a while at least until they start
kindergarten yes exactly
but we did also have another piece of
mcu content released recently that we
should also consider when talking about
souls because in episode four of what if
we saw what would happen if doctor
strange's heart was broken instead of
his hands and during this episode we see
the ancient one speak to strange after
she had already died she appears through
a portal and has the same translucent
appearance that we often associate with
the astral projections that we've seen
before in the mcu and the ancient one
calls what's happening a psychic
impression sent through a splinter in
reality and she also says that steven
should just think of her as an echo so
what the hell is this thing anyway like
is she actually a soul conversing with
doctor strange from the afterlife this
echo of the ancient one is able to
converse with stephen even going as far
as to answer very specific questions and
the echo doesn't last long before it
disappears and the story moves on but
it's still pretty cool nonetheless yeah
except for that they tried so hard to
just be like how do we not step on star
wars toes
right
everything about that scene was like she
should have just said like this is not
like the force whatever you're thinking
i am not a force ghost it's possible
that the ancient one was able to make a
sort of spiritual copy or echo of
herself and set it forward through that
splinter of reality and this echo almost
seems to operate like the living
paintings that we see in harry potter
one of my favorite movie franchises uh
based on a book that wrote itself and
the subjects in these paintings are
enchanted and are often able to converse
like their actual physical counterparts
even going as far to use catchphrases
the actual person would use however
there was a limit to how in-depth of a
conversation a real person could have
with an enchanted painting the enchanted
paintings are able to exist well beyond
the life of the painting subject so
the ancient one's echo is not really the
ancient one's soul it's more of like a
pre-recorded ai that disappears once it
has served its purpose yeah so there you
go that's pretty much the lowdown on
souls in the mcu and
i really like especially with the echo
part of like you know that was
introduced in what if i really hope that
they go into the concept of echoes and
maybe strange could like have a
conversation with all the past social
supremes like avatar the last airbender
style yeah that'd be pretty really dope
i'd like to see everybody just to give
stephen advice about how not to pick up
because steven is uh he's she's too
curious he's a curiosity killed the cat
he's just kind of a dead gonna be a
couple cats killed in no way
let me tell you that that is it for our
first question but be sure to head on
over to do rockstarsmerch.com to check
out our latest merch including our
latest obsession shirt inspired by
shanghi like it's literally super dope
and it is the eighth design in the
latest obsession line of collectible
shirts by new rockstars each shirt
design is selected by the new rockstars
team to celebrate what we're obsessing
over right now and on the caller is a
numbered shirt label to identify the
collectible shirt as unique in the
exclusive series and this is now issue
number eight so once this shirt goes out
of stock the number will be forever
retired from the latest obsession lineup
forever so like you only have one chance
to get the number for the shirt and
we've got a whole line of suicide squad
merch and a spider-man no way
home-inspired shirt and a bunch of other
great gear and grabbing something from
new rockstarsmerch.com is an awesome way
to support this channel and to show the
world that you love your favorite fandom
and it's just a great way to meet new
nerds because everyone be complimenting
on these shirts man like every time i
wear this loki shirt like it's always
like oh my god where'd you get that
shirt and it's like
new rockstars birch.com what are you new
what are you a peasant get away from me
i can't wait till comic cons come back
and we can all wear our new rockstar
shirts at them and smile at each other
like people who own mustangs that give
each other a thumbs up on the highway
that's what it's going to be exactly
before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the folks
that help bring big question to you
folks like coinbase lots of folks feel
crypto fomo the fear of missing out on
cryptocurrency and it can feel like a
secret or an exclusive club that you're
locked out of but coinbase believes that
everyone everywhere should be able to
get to the door so whether or not you've
been trading for years or are just
getting started coinbase can help and
coinbase offers a trusted and easy to
use platform to buy sell and spread
cryptocurrency and they support the most
popular digital currencies on the market
and make them accessible to everyone and
they offer portfolio management and
protection learning resources and a
mobile app so you can trade securely and
monitor your crypto all in one place
millions of people in over 100 countries
trust coinbase with their digital assets
and whether you're just getting started
or searching for a better way to access
crypto markets start today with coinbase
sign up at coinbase.com bigquestion for
five dollars in free bitcoin this offer
is for a limited time only so be sure to
sign up today that is coinbase.com
big question the nfl season has started
and teams are back out on the gridiron
draftkings the official daily fantasy
partner of the nfl is putting you in the
center of the action for week two of the
season new customers can get a free shot
at millions of dollars in total prizes
with their first deposit by signing up
using the code bigquestion and get in on
the action right now it's simple just
pick your lineup stay under the salary
cap and see how your team stacks up
against the competition and do
exhaustive research and pick the most
probable winning lineup or just pick the
guys you like to watch to play feel the
nfl action like never before with a free
shot at millions of dollars in total
prizes so download the draftkings app
now and use the code big question and
this week new customers can get a free
shot at millions of dollars in total
prizes so enter the code big question to
get a free shot at millions in total
prizes with your first deposit that is
code big question only at draftkings the
official daily fantasy partner of the
nfl minimum five dollar deposit required
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com for details all right
tommy i got a bite size question for you
ready for this one
oh yeah my chompers are ready yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum do it
so tell me we're the flora colossus you
know groot species made from a piece of
igrasil the world tree and this is from
crispy chrissy on discord thank you
chrissy yes thank you crispy chrissy
i hope she's the crispiest i can't wait
to get nice and crispy tonight groot
species aka the flora colossi are
anthropomorphic tree species living on
planet x i'm from planet triplex cause
i'm naughty and i'm nasty oh [ __ ] the
state of the union i'm from a very small
town where we pick apples we don't know
too much about their species compared to
a lot of other fleshed out no pun
intended species and marvel comics what
the comics do tell us is the flora
colossi are strong and durable
plant-based beings capable of healing
themselves through cellular regeneration
they are ruled by an elite monarchy
known as the arbor masters
and the species passes down accumulated
knowledge and experience of generations
through a process of photosynthesis how
about that
what if we could just learn through
photosynthesis
photosynthesis
instead of going to be amazing
school is stupid i want to learn from
the sun exactly i'm not going to college
mom i'm going out in the sun this
photonic knowledge makes the flora
colossi incredibly intelligent those are
some smart trees my friends
now as for them being made of a piece of
yggdrasil it's hard to say for example
there is likely no physical industrial
holding the realms together at least
certainly not one that is a giant tree
rather yigdrazel is a concept to
describe the cosmic cloud of stars that
connect the nine realms you know basic
stuff however yeah it is possible
that the recently introduced ember of
genesis could have played a role in the
creation of the flora colosse the
emperors of genesis showed up in episode
two of what if
ellipse question mark and appear to have
no equivalent in marvel comics according
to the episode they come from an ancient
supernova and they have the power to
heal a dying planet well for god's sakes
send us some of those embers because it
is flooding in the bronx okay
we
saw how they quickly grew huge plant i'm
not making a joke out of that by the way
i'm terrified so we really do need those
episodes of genesis oh my god
that is an avengers level threat so it's
fine though i'm sure it's fine we should
just keep drilling in the gulf uh we saw
how they quickly grew huge plant-like
stalks on nowhere when nebula tossed
them into call obsidian's mouth could we
soon learn that the embers of genesis
were the original source of the flora
colosse
it's possible my friends that was a
great bite-sized question and i'm
certainly filling up but i'm not
completely full yet mt toss me another
one of those bite-sized babies tommy who
was the first villain spider-man faced
in the comics and this is from steel
force corn on twitter thank you seal
forced corn a lot of butter to get that
corn down in the amazing spiderman
volume one issue one friendly
neighborhood spiderman faces his first
big foe the color-changing dastardly
palette of
evil chameleon this villain in
particular she had spider-man and did a
bunch of bad stuff around new york city
making our hero look bad which is just a
son of a jerk thing to do this would set
the precedent of people not trusting
spider-man for years to come isn't that
just the
backbone of spider-man comics is that
everyone doesn't trust him no matter how
much good he tries to do chameleon aka
demetrius merdiakov originally had no
real powers he would use makeup to labra
costumes to impersonate people along
with a belt buckle that would emit a gas
that enabled him to mold his facial
features i mean that's pretty cool over
the years the belt buckle got upgraded
over and over to make it more impressive
technologically eventually chameleon
powers up and gets the skin cells
mutagenically altered by a special serum
i wish i could have that this along with
some memory material fabric allows him
to physically shape-shift to resemble
anyone it's also later revealed that
he's the half-brother of craven the
hunter ah 23 and me can do anything
right oh my god bringing people together
what's interesting is that chameleon may
have already been revealed in the mcu in
spider-man far from home the mysterious
chaperone accompanying the group that is
secretly working with nick fury and
maria hill is named dimitri and remember
as we said the chameleons will name the
comic is dimitri smedjarkavov smed
smeared smirdiakov and remember
everybody already as we've already
mentioned the chameleon's real name is
demetrius medjerkoff and in the film the
nick fury and maria hill that he's
working for are actually the skrulls
talos and sauron so it's possible they
are making demetrius medjarkov in the
mcu a scroll rather than a
shape-shifting human the director john
watts was even asked about this
character specifically and he said we're
not specifically saying he's the
chameleon but we're not not saying it so
that's a non-answer i guess we'll just
have to wait and see if good old
demeantry shows up again and whose side
he's working on now because if there's
one thing we know about chameleons they
don't stay the same very long i'm tom
beck told this has been a big question
all right wonderful yeah that was a
wonderful response but i do love the
idea that the comedian could have some
ties to the scrolls because
chameleon was a squirrel that would be
pretty cool just to have that
integration but
because the mcu is this heavily
science-based universe it'd be cool if
they like were to take a scroll during
secret invasion dissect how the
squirrels like shape-shift and like have
chameleon sort of adopt the scroll like
science into how he does his thing so
like a good way to like
you know follow up the whole squirrel
secret invasion thing yes with uh you
know chameleon but yeah no that was
amazing tommy thank you so much my
pleasure it is time for my favorite part
of the show it's time for the box of
scraps
about some scraps now tommy you know
since we got shang chi dealing with the
concept of the soul and all this stuff
it's got me thinking you know tommy what
would be your idea of the perfect
afterlife oh
perfect
afterlife oh
well that's a pretty heady question you
know i mean
it is we're talking a day to day i'd say
for me i simply like to wake up
there's uh
there's an omelette waiting for me with
mushrooms bacon and cheddar cheese that
omelette has been made for me by uh
my two wives uh kate upton and uh
vita guerra i'm gonna age myself a
little bit by saying peter guerra we eat
the omelet and then we do our morning
workout and then i go to my job
at the skydiving factory where you
skydive all day but there's never any
risk of you dying so it's just a
perpetual roller coaster after that's
over i drive home in my flying car
at which point my two gorgeous wives
have
been missing me so much that they greet
me at the door with just butterfly
kisses which of course as we all know
are kisses with your eyelashes at that
point we settle in for a night of uh you
know prestige television of which we can
watch any channel without any
subscription fees and we go to bed
around 9 30 and that would be the
perfect afterlife for me mt what about
you buddy honestly you stole my answer
just kidding
it was exactly that it was exactly that
i would probably just live in the
hundred acre wood honestly because i
just i love the booze so much and like
the hundred acre wood in where the poo
is always just so chill and like nothing
bad happens there and like it's
everything just so peaceful like it's
just nature and like yeah your neighbors
are kind of annoying and kind of stupid
but they're cute i love the ball there's
that one depressed guy who lives in a
tent by the freeway yeah eeyore would be
a little bit more uh you know i'd be
very concerned about eeyore i'm trying
to help him be less depressed because
you can't help those who don't want to
be helped mt i've learned that this year
this is true so my depressed ass would
probably make ior even more depressed
i'd be there i'd be right there with you
my friend right there with you
oh wow well i'm that depressing
well i'm not depressing down it has been
this has been a big question thank you
so much for watching and thank you of
course to tommy for joining me this
episode you can follow tommy at
tommybecktold on twitter and you can
follow me at mastertainment if you want
to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly follow new rockstars on
twitter because tyler is on twitter
doing some amazing things and also
please hit that notification bell on
youtube so you can get notifications
whenever we upload a new video anyway
thank you so much for watching and we
will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you